aux etats unis pour la première fois une
femme décédée d'une maladie des poumons
a été reconnu comme nouvelles victimes
les attentats du world trade center du
11 septembre 2001 il s'agit d'une
avocate de 42 ans avait fui son bureau
et traversé le nuage de poussière elle
était mort cinq mois après les attentats
plusieurs milliers de personnes se
trouvant sur le site de ground zero
pendant ou après l'attentât s'offre de
pathologies respiratoires
alain seulement un nom va prochainement
être ajoutées sur le mémorial des
victimes du 11-septembre le 2007 150e
celui de felicia jon jones morte cinq
mois après les attentats
avocate elle travaillait dans le secteur
du world trade center et avait respiré
le nuage toxique provoquée par
l'effondrement des tours nuage formé de
cendres de minuscules morceaux de verre
d'amiante et de plomb après cinq ans de
procédure son décès a finalement été
reconnu par la ville de new york comme
une conséquence des attentats c'est un
grand honneur
et là on a toujours pensé qu'elle
méritait de faire partie des victimes a
mené ce presque sans voix
cette décision pourrait faire
jurisprudence au bénéfice de ces
milliers de sauveteurs professionnels ou
bénévoles ou encore simples citoyens qui
souffrent de maladies respiratoires et
on les pires difficultés à les faire
reconnaître depuis le 11 septembre
la famille de ce capitaine de police de
new york vit un cauchemar
il est pratiquement cloué au lit un
poids pour les siens j'aime mon pays
comme je le dis si c'était à refaire je
le referai mais c'est clair on n'est que
rogers que des pions qu'on peut
interchanger dans cette situation le jeu
d'échecs
ce n'est que cinq ans après les
attentats
et après avoir supplié oui monde y est
dans un dédale bureaucratique
on a fini par reconnaître que sa maladie
où on sait tant mais il a fallu se
battre pour chaque dollar d'un dancing
obama s'est aussi elle dès lors en
iphone
le précédent créé par l'inscription de
felicia day jaune sur la liste des
victimes pourrait changer un peu cette
manière tatillonne et bureaucratique de
traiter ceux qui étaient hier des héros
est aujourd'hui sont des boulets